feel your life bonjour on se retrouve
aujourd'hui au centre de contrôle contre
le plus point fr val d'europe et on va
rejoindre jean michael qui est
contrôleur technique agréé ce sera
l'occasion pour nous de revenir sur les
différentes étapes qui constitue un
contrôle technique mais aussi de lui
poser des questions sur un nouveau
contrôle technique qui est arrivé le 1er
juillet 2019 c'est parti bonjour
enchantés de chanter la chanson de
ce véhicule donc
tout bonnement je commence par prendre
les numéros de série
l'état du plateau
en passant de baronne dénombre que dit
sur mon europe sur ma propre plaque
numéro d' indices pour la pollution qui
est de 0,5 entre ici et puis je commence
doucement à moncontour
donc maintenant les notifications et
terminait est terminée alors je vais
commencer par mettre mes pneus en
ampliation voir s'ils sont à la bonne
pression si c'est pas le cas je l'aimais
vérifie qu'ils soient bien pour pouvoir
faire mes appareils de mesure dans les
bonnes conditions alors la mesure en
général mais 2,5 avant deux-trois
d'arrière sinon je peux aller récupérer
les valeurs directement sur la plaque du
véhicule qui est sur le côté gauche du
véhicule
je regarde je vous raconte niveau de vie
les biens
je suis pas trop je suis pas trop bas
donc je vais pouvoir attaquer ma
position
qu'est ce qui a changé le 1er juillet du
groupe non ça faisait partie déjà des
enseignants parce qu'un moteur où il n'y
a pas assez du loup qui a produit le
risque de s'emballer rapidement du coup
casse moteur
donc pour éviter ce genre de problème on
vérifie bien avant que le niveau et les
lille est bon alors on concède à cette
étape déjà je vais démarrer le véhicule
le brancher mon appareil bdc présent je
vais vérifier s'il n'y a pas d'anomalie
moteur lui il va aller discuter avec le
calculateur pour voir s'il ya un
problème si le voyant en bd allumés sur
le tableau de bord ou sur l'ordinateur
de bord donc du coup je vais le
contacter pour avoir un premier cran et
je vérifie que m'envoyaient en bd est
bienvenue mais s'il est bien présent je
branche mon aux bd sur la prise au bd
qui situe sur le véhicule et je vais me
positionner sur mon appareil je vérifie
que ma plaque elle est bien là j'envoie
à elles demandent ces appareils bien
connecté simon témoins et bien annulé
moteur tournant aux motards arrêtés
si c'est le cas je valide et je lance à
la recherche
on paye va essayer de reconnaître
plusieurs protocoles parce que le
véhicule calculateur et discute pas avec
le même protocole sur chaque appareil
ces véhicules là il va essayer de
trouver le bon le bon dialogue pour
discuter avec une fois qu'il l'a trouvé
il va regarder à l'intérieur il va voir
si tout va bien et va me donner les
résultats
tarif de monde le voyant les biens et un
bon contact a eu lieu
donc il est bien éteint on valide et là
on a accès à aux informations sur lequel
il ya bien que mon voyant est allumée
contact et un moteur tournant il est
bien l'état et sur le calculateur il est
bien éteint
j'ai aucune liste de défauts même en
mineur donc c'est à dire que le
calculateur est bon je passe à la
production je réfléchis mais
informations à sont bonnes
si tout va bien j'y vais là par rapport
à la nouvelle norme jean qu'il dit
véhicule spécifique avec le coefficient
d'absorption puis il a été reporté
depuis la part la plaque du moteur donc
on est bon on est à 0 ça qu'on envoie
les maintenant faut que j'atteigne les
80 degrés afin de pouvoir faire mon
mon mât pollution
[Musique]
alors je viens serema sombre
l'échappement pour récupérer les valeurs
alors normalement si tout va bien je
vais devoir faire deux accélérations à
une certaine vitesse
alors là c'est une voiture allemande
donc l'accélération va être bloquée un
certain nombre de tours lui par rapport
au nombre de tours il va calculer le
lait roger des gaz et voir s'il y a trop
ou pas assez de deux d'élimination
voilà haute et se terminer alors là on a
notre et quand on voit bien que les deux
accélérations sont nettement inférieurs
à la limite maximum de pas citer le
véhicule est bon y passe c'est cette
limite là qui a été changée duquel a été
changé et cette limite l'avarice selon
les véhicules y en a qui ont aucune
autre imitant n'est que nous aurons des
plus basses
quand une fois que c'est fait je vais
faire l'intérieur du véhicule je vais
vérifier mes ceintures je vais vérifier
si mon volant il bloque bien je vais
vérifier le pilote en lice klaxon je
vérifier tout ça et voir s'ils en
attendent véhicules et confort
tiens bien si le verra le maintiennent
en l'air si tout va bien mais bon
j'aurais fait un petit peu si le
plancher
quand on peut y accéder n'a pas été
déformé s'il n'a pas pris de choc
les portières se sont bien en place se
souvient cette ferme bien vite si elles
tiennent
le
mon moteur
soumet poule tiennent
april est en place
si j'ai des bouchons qui sont bien fixés
[Musique]
là je vais vérifier la hauteur des voeux
pour ça je vais mal eu mes enfants mes
mains d'antibes il ya six ans
à étant donné que ce sont des fautes de
main il se règle automatiquement par
rapport à la hauteur de la voiture
sélectionnez la plaque
m
wei
trois parcours
dans la zec
on voit que je suis
au même niveau des deux côtés pour tout
va bien
le positionne devant mon premier fort
l'appareil me demande
le guerrier
vérifie aussi si la hauteur du fort par
rapport au sol est bien avancée du tout
là donc là je suis un père yeraz au
sélectionneur
vos potes
par là je demandé
aussi mon sac moins 0,5 et moi 2 1
non je vais passer au freinage je vais
librement
toujours sélection de ma plaque alors là
je dis ça en 82
position je peux faire une contre-visite
sur un certain type d'appareil bouge
ferme complet sélectionne complet je
vérifie si l'on fasse un frein à main
électrique on appréhende la normale là
c'est un fait anormal
les informations sont bonnes on peut
commencer de plage
mbia les informations qu'on voit là bas
elles sont enregistrées
elles sont envoyées à l'ordinateur et
son calcul est alors par rapport au
poids du véhicule et à la force de
freinage et ça doit arriver à une
certaine ouvreur pourquoi être acceptée
mais mon véhicule afin de voir comment
ça se passe et du jeu si mes pneus vont
bien ce sont des bons mecs
voilà
[Musique]
en hd vérité
bloc de problème
si mes 19 ans sont pas trop creuser
les amortisseurs s'ils ont pas puis les
ressources it young boys
s'il n'y a pas de jeu
braga béton
où est sarko aurait également
attention à mes pneus je verrai si c'est
les bonnes marques sont messieurs s'ils
sont pas trop abîmer
c'est la bonne vague
en dessous du véhicule pour vérifier les
voeux la toscane est intacte si à l'abri
de choc
le montant
si chicane intérieur du silence une son
poids mans
m
puis descend de la voiture et rentrer
d'avoir son propriétaire en lui
expliquant chaque défaut
mais ce que celle l'appréhender des
dépôts celle là elle est toute propre